digamos que tenemos una solución
saturada de fluoruro de calcio en
equilibrio con fluoruro de calcio sólido
entonces en nuestro vaso de precipitado
aquí tenemos algo de fluoruro de calcio
sólido que es un compuesto iónico
ligeramente soluble y en solución
tenemos una solución saturada que
consiste en calcio 2 + y añón es de
fluoruro ahora digamos que agregamos
algo de ácido entonces agregamos una
fuente de protones a nuestro vaso de
precipitados y observamos lo que sucede
bueno veríamos disolverse parte de
nuestro fluoruro de calcio y digamos que
agregamos suficiente ácido para disolver
completamente nuestro cloruro de calcio
entonces lo que pasa aquí es que
agregamos ácido cierto
cree vamos
h más por lo tanto disminuimos el d h
vimos disolverse el fluoruro de calcio
entonces aumentamos la solubilidad
solubilidad
cierto aumentamos la solubilidad de
nuestro compuesto de fluoruro de calcio
ligeramente soluble entonces veamos si
podemos descifrar qué sucedió por
agregar h más sabemos que hay h2o
presente entonces h más y h2o nos dan h
3 o más entonces tenemos iones de
hidrógeno en solución y también tenemos
iones de fluoruro en solución y el
fluoruro puede funcionar como una base
entonces los anones de fluoruro van a
funcionar como una base y el hidro nio
funciona como un ácido si tenemos dos
años de fluoruro se necesitarían dos
iones de hidrógeno
entonces el hidro no actúa como un ácido
dona un protón y el avión de fluoruro
actúa como una base
un protón entonces hacemos hf hacemos 2h
efe aquí
y si h3o más dona un protón también
tenemos dos moléculas de agua entonces
tenemos dos h2o aquí también entonces
pensemos en lo que estamos haciendo a la
concentración de iones de fluoruro en la
solución los iones de fluoruro están
reaccionando por lo que está
disminuyendo la concentración de iones
de fluoruro en la solución y recordemos
el principio del yaqui a un sistema cuyo
equilibrio ha sido perturbado cambiará
su equilibrio para disminuir el esfuerzo
aplicado entonces aquí el esfuerzo ha
disminuido la concentración de uno de
nuestros productos el equilibrio cambia
para hacer más de un producto y así por
lo tanto se disuelve más fluoruro de
calcio con lo que hemos aumentado la
solubilidad del cloruro de calcio
incluso podemos escribir la reacción
total de lo que está sucediendo aquí
entonces en la reacción neta podemos ver
que tenemos dos años de fluoruro en el
lado de los reactivos y también tenemos
dos años de fluoruro en el lado de los
productos entonces podemos tomar estos
dos y decir que son nuestros reactivos
así que tenemos fluoruro de calcio más
dos hidrógenos
más
2 h 3 o más y obtendremos para nuestros
productos obtendremos a estos de aquí
obtendremos co2 más iones de calcio y
haremos 2 h
efe
solución
y también agua
entonces esta es otra forma de pensar en
lo que está sucediendo si agregas un
ácido al cloruro de calcio vas a obtener
estos productos
entonces agregar protones agregar ha
sido disminuir el ph aumenta la
solubilidad de este compuesto
ligeramente soluble pero esto no es
siempre cierto depende de qué compuesto
se esté hablando por ejemplo para
cloruro de plata este es otro compuesto
ligeramente soluble pero agregara ácido
no afecta la solubilidad del cloruro de
plata ahora pensemos en el porqué si
agregas ácido estás aumentando la
concentración de iones de hidrógeno en
la solución y lo que pasó arriba es que
los aviones de fluoruro reaccionaron con
los iones de hidrógeno para cambiar el
equilibrio pero aquí los aviones de
cloruro no reaccionarán con el idóneo y
esto es porque los aviones de cloruro
son una base mucho más débil que el
avión de fluoruro
entonces pensemos sobre esto aquí arriba
el año de floruro si piensas sobre el h
efe su base con jugada es el efe - aquí
abajo para el año en cloruro sería hcl
cuya base con jugada es cl - entre más
fuerte es el ácido más débil es la base
entonces
hcl es un ácido fuerte un ácido mucho
más fuerte que hf y por lo tanto cl - la
base con jugada es mucho más débil
entonces el año de cloruro es una base
más débil que el avión de fluoruro
entonces el avión de cloruro no va a
reaccionar con hidro nio y por lo tanto
no estamos disminuyendo la concentración
de uno de los productos y el equilibrio
no cambia y no se afectan la solubilidad
del cloruro de plata por la adición de
un ácido
entonces disminuir el ph para el cloruro
de plata no aumentará la solubilidad
entonces tienes que pensar si la base es
lo suficientemente fuerte para
reaccionar con el ácido que estás
agregando